alors oui direct bah oui je compte vous
présentait donc bas d'ici là jean la
semaine là je dors maintenant
officiellement nathan un contrat et puis
on se dit on devrait le mettre pour
présenter officiellement comme comment
tu a mûri sa décision
pour te présenter qu'est ce qui fait
pencher la balance
bah quoi qu'il arrive et cette année je
me présentais quand même puisque c'est
ma troisième année donc je commence à me
faire vieux donc étant donné que j'ai
fait une plutôt bonne année cette année
pour la troisième
du coup c'était légitime de me présenter
et de commencer à faire le processus
commence à marcher voire un petit peu
mettre un peu les process du coup ben là
avec tout ce qui se passe avec le micro
et tout du coup bah ça retarde un peu
l'échéance puis un bon fait pas trop
syfia ça valait le coup et du coup une
amende a décidé que quand même ça serait
important de le mettre mon coeur ce
qu'on veut est ce que tu vas garder
l'option de revenir à la fac pourtant
les seigneurs ou pas ouais bien sûr les
gens comme une année d'éligibilité donc
donc du gain ne soit possible
ok donc comment tu quand tu a procédé au
niveau des gens qui donnent des conseils
ou pas même si toi tu avais prévu de te
présenter tu m'as dit est ce que tu as
parlé avec le coach avec des anciens
coéquipiers qui sont là une vieille
exactement j'ai beaucoup parlent que le
premier assistant coach beaucoup avec
lui j'ai beaucoup parlé avec mon mentor
j'ai aussi demandé aux agences et
intimes mais qui sont anciens billets
donc à nos moeurs cauchy williams
qu'alexander et un est aussi jordan
bonne donc ouais je leur ai demandé ce
qu'il avait des rotours des retours
votre similaire pour leur troisième
année donc voilà donc j'aurai donc
déconseillé ce qu'ils avaient fait à
quelqu'un infections y avait eu donc
pourquoi j'ai de bons retours
[Musique]